so how can a woman keep you grounded
because I think I think I struggle with
that I think I mean my husband comes
home he can be pretty stressed out for
work because like you said work is chaos
so I'm like well like what do I do do I
hug him do I leave him alone I think
he's the leave him alone give uh let him
play video games kind of Route so like
how can a woman be grounding to you guys
what's what would peace look like if she
could do it oh okay
it's not simple it just comes down to
silence and then just doing the things
that she normally would do for you
taking care of you sitting next to you
like just you know peace peace generally
is seen as silence if you're in peace if
you're in you know people say Zen it is
pure silence the guy wants to come home
to a nice quiet home most of the time he
doesn't want to come home to chaos peace
is normally described as silence okay
not for me I think the Deep obviously
loyally and cooperative and
the friend and feminine are all key
things but I think the most important
thing is deep understanding now there's
levels of understanding and I think with
understanding comes trust so if you get
to know the man and you really want to
fulfill your man and want to see him win
then you're going to let him lead and I
think a lot of it boils down to trust
there's a lot of people saying oh I love
my man I love my man but for one reason
or the other they're the biggest
holdback sometimes so I think that men I
think men realize when a girl genuinely
wants to see him win not just for her
benefit and for me I think that's the
that's the key thing and with that when
a female's trusting you comes femininity
a lot of men are thinking oh why is my
girl masculine because she's not trusted
you so I think that's what I think
that's what it boils down to so I hear
that I hear where you say it you wanna
you wanna come home and you want silence
and peace
but now if she's silent it could be a
bit of a problem she can talk about me
well that's what I was saying is like
what if you're coming home and uh you're
stressed or you're feeling down what if
you wanna like you want I know something
encouraging what would that look like
because one of my girlfriends has told
me that when her man is stressed out
that she just gives him a big hug so I
think I was looking for like those kind
of actions obviously you know being
quiet in the midst of chaos is helpful
that's what I think too because a lot of
times when guys say what they want it it
sounds really simple which okay and but
it's very Broad and so it's like if you
were gonna say to someone all right I
want to be a wife how do I become one
like what would you tell them to do go
ahead let me is it Aliyah oh yes so I
can't speak for all men can't speak for
your your husband however
I can tell you about me so if I came
back from work and I was stressed
all my other half would have to do
if I had one would be
nothing
like silence
chill
okay
um there's not even that much pressure
on you to to
um yeah like just have something ready
for us to eat together
yeah
um and then just chill
let me you don't need to ground me or
anything like that like I've been
grouting myself for 35 years I'm very
very good at grounding myself and all
the rest of it just don't don't add to
the stress yeah that's that's it okay
that's an action a lot of girls a lot of
girls I'm not saying all girls a lot of
girls somehow still find a way to just
not be able to do nothing they they find
a way to want to add to the stress it's
like they've been waiting for you to
come home all day just to tell you
something you have to get on your nerves
you know sometimes it's like all right a
man's just happy just to see you like
just just be just exist and be feminine
so I can give you my full masculine but
if you're acting frantic and all
masculine how can you expect me to be
masculine well you know it's not it's
not like that so like I stay home um and
then so my husband's gone like 10 to 12
hours a day and you know when I see him
I just get so excited I'm like oh my God
I can't wait to tell you about my day
and he's like 30 minutes an hour 30
minutes an hour and I'm ready to hear
about your day so like we don't we don't
we're not trying to add to your plate
but I see your point so it's called a
decompression time is what a lot of
counselors call it apparently men need
that I feel like I don't think women are
like that I don't feel like I need not
even like five minutes to myself no
because we're more social so to us like
when we come home we're excited to talk
to each other but men aren't like that
they're like Get Away have you ever seen
that have you ever seen that Chris Rock
I think it's Chris Rock where he's like
we like you there but not there okay
I want to be with you but you know I
don't really I want to be around you so
you could just be in the air vent that's
what Patrice O'Neill said oh God no I
was going to say I think as men
I think we're very self-aware in the
sense that how we want to make sure that
we receive our woman properly so
sometimes we may need like half an hour
to just to decompress but I think
sometimes women take offense to that
when they say give me like 30 minutes
why are you mad at me
and it's like it's not about you babe
it's me just give me 30 minutes that's a
hard concept for them to grab that's not
about them because they always think
it's about them but that's why you get
guys sort of sitting in the car when
they get back from work for 10 minutes
just to have a moment to themselves to
go into the house because hey it's like
you know I don't mean this
disrespectfully but you know when you
have a puppy and they run to the door
when you come through the door it's a
bit like that it's nice it's nice it's
not supposed to be of course
disrespectful but it's like the
excitement to see you it is lovely but
like you said you need to just five
minutes just let me just chill for two
seconds I mean I'd actually also add it
it depends on your current like position
in the relationship so what what like if
you're in the honeymoon period I'd say
it's a lot more romantic and full-on and
more sexually driven at that point in
the first like six months of normal
relationships a lot of sex happens so in
that case the man would be anticipating
that as soon as he gets home if I was
married I'd expect some form of intimacy
as soon as I get home if it was the
first but obviously let's say 10 years
down the line if I'm working and if
things are chailed together can I get
home I'm just going to want to relax I'm
just going to want to sit decompress as
you've said and then eventually after a
while maybe have dinner and then during
dinner start conversation and then keep
the conversation going overnight
but the whole point is you need men need
that decompression when they get home if
they're not because the thing is men the
thing is if it's not the honeymoon
period and it's not a part where he's
very sexually driven and he can't wait
to get home to literally rail you
against the bed then you literally need
the position off he needs peace he needs
to relax for a bit because if he doesn't
get that he's just gonna build up even
more stress and it's going to get
bottled then he might explode and even
and some men explode in different ways
and then yeah I'd say that's the main
that's the Crux of the situation yeah I
think I think the main thing I can speak
for all men I think all men want respect
definitely it was I think it boils down
to respect when a man is disrespected he
can do crazy things let's be honest oh
man I think disrespect even leads men to
cheating which never really wants to get
spoken about it's always this guy's a
bad guy for cheating but let's ask
ourselves how many times how many times
did you disrespect your man before he
cheated that's like every single like
school shooter story I've ever thought
yeah I mean we we want respect from men
let alone our women do you know what I
mean like respect is number one be
Beyond love beyond beyond anything
respect is one and then well a woman has
to respect you in order to love you in
the first place it starts with respect I
think I think without respect it doesn't
work it cannot work if the girl actually
wants she's gonna have to get to the
point where she has to respect you or
she has to find someone she does respect
yeah the relationship doesn't work
without respect otherwise you get a lot
of problems just developing and actually
growing it's like a seed if you if
there's no respect it's gonna grow yeah
it's gonna literally grow and ruin
things and it gets ruined in different
ways so you guys you guys know why we
disrespect you guys right okay this
looks like for the for the women that
love you that get out of pocket okay
because there's just like some naturally
psychotic women that's like she's just
gonna be out of pocket for everyone so
the way uh there's a doctor his name is
Dr egrets he talks about love and
respect right and it's in the Bible too
where women are commanded to respect
their husbands and husbands are
commanded to love their wives right and
there's a reason for that and so when
when I feel unloved we tend to get
disrespectful and then if you feel like
I'm disrespecting you you're gonna go
out of your way to make sure that I
don't feel loved and you're not gonna
cuddle with me and it goes into this
cycle and you never know when to hop off
because it's like well do I want to hop
off no he should hop off when really
it's like once you know you're in the
cycle you should just hop off just for
the greater good whoever figures it out
first so yeah I think that that's a
that's a common thing because um when
men blow up nobody ever asks what did
she say and I feel like we should start
asking because it's really bad because
they always if if a girl blows up it's
what did he do yeah yeah but we never
asked what did she say and so many times
that one oh well what did you do what
did you do it's not about me I'm not a
narcissist it's about it's true we have
to and we have to remember as well it's
respect isn't just in the home when
we're outside your females representing
you if she's representing you in a mad
way she's not respecting you so I think
it's such a 360 thing yeah you've got
like obviously when you come home from
work but on the flip side you've got how
she's representing you outside if she if
your girl does not respect and rate you
you'll hear him know about it and it
will burn but girl a girl asked me the
other day ago that I'm talking to and um
she said to me
um so babes like how would you want me
to be like say we were a thing like I
would you know and I said uh I want you
to pretend you're always wearing a
permanent T-shirt with my face on it so
you know no matter where you are you
you're wearing a t-shirt and it's got my
face on it
and and that's the mindset that you need
to have because when they've when
they've got that in their mind
they're acting it out there's no it's
like a constant romance yeah exactly
what are some ways that a woman can
demonstrate respect because again like
respect very Broad and we ain't got no
doubt he's just like y'all don't got
daddies so what how can we demonstrate
by listening just look out in there I do
think that like a good woman is going to
test you as a man I don't think there
should be like an unrealist unrealistic
expectation that a woman's not going to
test you and it's good because as a man
you need to be on your A game so a good
one was going to test you and you need
to be like the best version of yourself
to be able to deal with that and kind of
make her fit into your frame just to add
that in I have to disagree with that one
uh yeah I was gonna say I completely
disagree I think respect is when she
doesn't do that like she respects you
should disrespect you by the way no no
I'm saying like she shouldn't even test
you like the whole point is when someone
respects you you don't like you don't
test your boss you don't go to your boss
and start testing them [ __ ] testing them
like oh what about this what about that
like at the end of the day it is the
kind of Boss Dynamic like at the end of
the day a relationship is you go to work
every day like I've just like it's just
it's really simple it sounds it's people
complicate a lot but when it comes to
respect just listen to what the man says
at the end of the day he has the final
say if you're in a dynamic relationship
where it's masculine feminine the man
has the final say and the Crux of it
really does literally come down to
listening respect not arguing
understanding that he has the final say
and that's literally how it should be
sort of boil it down
she has to listen yeah listen that's
actionable items whatever the man says
does do so she listens yeah yeah okay
and you know what not to not to
disrespect my brother here and or
anybody else on the panel but no tests
yeah
because this is
you might be right but in my in my world
it's not unrealistic because listen I'm
tested every day yeah up at 6am working
from eight till nine most days seven
days a week no tests that's enough if
you test to become part of the problem I
I don't I don't think that I don't think
I know a single wife that doesn't test
their husband now I think there are
malicious ways to test your husband I
think that's true but there's other ways
that you're going to be tested so like
example you know fatherhood that's
that's a test is to see like you know
how do you perform as a father and a
husband I don't think you're going to be
able to get away from it and so I live
in the Midwest and so there's a feminine
wise masculine husbands in the church
husbands are providers protectors women
are feminine submissive but there there
are still going to be tests like you
still want your boundaries respected as
a human being and an individual I I
understand what you're saying like don't
be malicious about it but I think it's
unrealistic to think that you know that
it's not going to happen at all so I'm
thinking I'm just going with that train
of thought as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible